[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight a pretty sad story
tonight one person is dead
the alleged killer may soon be roaming
the streets free why is that well
because leaders of the Democratic Party
are starting to believe internalize the
belief act on the belief that illegal
aliens have more rights than American
citizens look at this picture this is
Ivan Zamora Castaneda look closely that
is in fact an Ace of Hearts tattoo on
his face but that's not the problem with
this man the problem is twofold first
he's an illegal alien second over the
weekend in Denver police say he got
drunk and slammed his car into a semi
truck the truck burst into flames
the driver was burned to death rather
than stay at the scene Samri / Castaneda
fled the scene he was later arrested now
he faces charges of vehicular homicide
and then politics got involved which is
why we're bringing this to your
attention tonight federal authorities
have asked Denver to detain this man so
he can be arrested on federal charges
and deported back to Mexico where he's
from and should be living but no they
can't
why because Denver is a sanctuary city
and that means that Democratic
politicians there are committed to
protecting the accused killer even if it
means he'll soon be loose in downtown
Denver and he may be as soon as he posts
a $25,000 bond he will be free to go
until his next court date that's
assuming he bothers to show up in court
and by the way why would he he snuck
into this country he's going to go to
court probably not when Democrats say
they're committed to protecting
undocumented immigrants this is who
they're talking about they believe the
legal aliens accused of murder deserve
to be protected from you more than you
deserve to be protected from them they
care more about Ivins amory picasa nada
than they care about you they'll ignore
an undermined federal law on his behalf
would they do that for you I don't think
so
Attorney General Jeff Sessions has filed
suit to stop insanity like this the
Department of Justice has sued the state
of California it's a sanctuary state
that has explicitly announced it will
punish citizens there for cooperating
with the federal government in the
pursuit of enforcing immigration law
Democrats in California are outraged by
what the Attorney General has done
they're calling him the real criminal
Jeff sessions said is simply not true
and I call upon them upon him to
apologize to the people of California to
bringing the mendacity of Washington to
California and trying to insert discord
and division how dare you vilify members
of our community by trying to frighten
the American public into thinking that
all undocumented residents are dangerous
criminals how dare you this is how the
left has begun to think if you believe
accused murderers who shouldn't be in
this country ought to go back to their
own countries you're the one who's out
of line if you believe in borders you're
a monster this isn't your country it
belongs to other people now that's the
message they're sending explicitly